in Churchill's folly author Christopher
Catherwood looks back at Britain's role
in the creation of modern Iraq he spoke
about it recently for an hour hello
everyone and welcome to borders a
Tyson's Corner we're very happy to have
at our store this evening
Christopher Catherwood Christopher is a
Cambridge University Asst University
historian and has served as a consultant
to British Prime Minister Tony Blair's
cabinet this summer he's a writer in
residence for the history department at
the University of Richmond here in
Virginia Christopher is with us tonight
to discuss his new book
Churchill's folly the book is a study on
the making of modern Iraq it explores
British colonial secretary Winston
Churchill's decision in the 1920s to
create the artificial monarchy of Iraq a
decision with calamitous consequences
playing out today some 80 years later if
you're interested in knowing the history
behind today's headlines
Churchill's folly is an essential read
here now to discuss it is author
Christopher Catherwood thank you well
thank you very much for coming and if
any of you can't understand my British
accent do wave a hand or something like
that it's very nice to be here
and this is actually a very nice
unexpected reunion for me because that
white who works here I first met at a
conference a beautiful Austrian castle
20 years ago and yet here 20 years later
here we are again and my wife is here
Paulette she's a Virginian so a true
American so I've learned to say things
like I'll be hornswoggled and things
like that and various other Virginian
phrases so I hope that what I say is
comprehensible to you and it's also very
nice to hear because the first time I've
done a book launch like this here in the
United States I've written books that
have been published in the States but
I've never actually done a launch so
it's free so thanks very much to
everybody at borders for welcoming me
this book here is Churchill's fully how
Winston Churchill created modern Iraq
and what it is is a classic story of a
book that I'd been meaning to write for
a long time and then suddenly the
publishers were desperate for me to
write having
that's an issue for some while I had the
idea quite a few years ago writing a
book on how Churchill created the State
of Iraq because in Cambridge I'm very
fortunate that I live very near the
Churchill archives they're literally
five minutes up the road and Churchill
was historians dream because he's one of
those people who saved absolutely
everything that he ever possessed so he
even saved railway tickets hotel bills
everything and so the church an archive
is a historians treasure trove and now
of course is actually more than just the
church Locke have several other famous
people left their archives there as well
and one of the people who left her her
archives there was mrs. Thatcher Lady
Thatcher I should call her and you can
actually see her hand fingers handbags
if you go there as well so everything
from Churchill's hotel bills to mrs.
Thatcher's handbags and what it does
have in in profusion is the is the
archive the Churchill had on how he
ended up creating the state of Iraq in
1921 now I want to go back a little bit
this is quite a the early history of
Iraq is quite a controversial area and
if there are people who are more expert
on it than I am
please identify yourself during Question
Time because in the early history of
Iraq what you really need to be is an
expert on Biblical Archaeology
because all the famous places we read
about in the Hebrew Bible II or we call
the Old Testament places like Babylon
and Nineveh and places like that they're
all in the Fertile Crescent and of
course for that matter Abraham came from
what's called the Col deze and that's
also in what's now Iraq now Iraq itself
means a well routed land and that's an
expression that goes back as early as
the 6th 7th century AD but it's
important to say that most historians
although will some will differ most
historians think that there's no such
place as what we now call iraq before
churchill created it in 1921 in other
words iraq is a brand new thing it's
something that church were created and a
few people around the table in in Cairo
Egypt in March 1920
because if you look at the original the
old part old parts of the sort of
existent parts of what's now Iraq they
were part of the great big empires the
Assyrian Empire and the Babylonian
Empire and then what's now Iraq was also
on the borderland between the great
Persian empires to the east and the
Roman empires to the west and some of
the urge in the early chapters of the
book I give it a little bit of detail on
this or I should say I'm not a biblical
archaeologist I do have a living in a
city in Cambridge England which is one
of the biggest biblical archaeology
libraries in it so I was able to do some
research but Iraq as a concept and
didn't really exist it was it was more
of a geographical expression then of
course in the seventh century you have
the foundation of Islam and we should
always remember that some of the
earliest inhabitants of it what's now
Iraq right up until the seventh century
were Christians Owen and so Iraq was
actually there's a very good case but
the walk was actually in all it by
origins at the time a Christian in the
seventh century a Christian country that
was overrun by by Islam and so the
Assyrian Christians on the cordilla and
Christians who live in Iraq at the
moment are still there I think there are
about a million Christians left in in
Iraq they are the descendants of the
original Christian pre Muslim Christian
majority and the most famous Iraqi
Christian of the 20th century was
probably more infamous as best way to
put it
there was Tareq Aziz who was Saddam
Hussein's Deputy Prime Minister and now
of course now that Iraq is becoming a
democracy one of the paradoxes is that
the Christians who were protected by
Saddam Hussein because he was fear or
fear in Islamic militancy the Christians
were persecuted Christians were
persecuted understand Hussein now of
course are fearing potential persecution
under what they think might be an
Islamist regime if it's such a regime as
democratically elected but then in the
7th century the Baghdad
part of the bigger was limit Muslim
world and at its peak the great big
Abbasid Caliphate went all the way from
Spain in the West right through to Iran
in the east and what's now Iraq was
actually part of an enormous empire and
so once again what we now called Iraq
was actually part of a much small unit
basically of a much wider Empire as in
stretching from Spain to Iran and so
there wasn't actually a single entity
though we could identify as being Iraq
and then after various sort of ups and
downs and various invasions including
the invasion of Baghdad and the Congress
of Baghdad by the Mongols in 1258 which
is regarded as great disaster in Muslim
history then then eventually after a
series of wars between different term
successor powers
what's now Iraq became part of the
budget game part of a much bigger Empire
the Ottoman Empire and the Ottoman
Empire lost him right up until 1918 and
in fact some people say that it actually
would have lasted longer had they not
made the fatal decision in 1914 to
desert the British in the French the two
powers had always supported them during
the 19th century and Ally instead with
Germany in Austria and therefore end up
on the losing side in 1918 so so far
that's the sort of basic background
that's sort of several thousand years of
history in a nutshell if you like and if
you want any more detail questions I'm
happy to give it a go the earlier you
get into biblical times the more shaky I
might be on Mike's expertise but I'll do
my best
then it was come the First World War
we've all heard of the Arab revolt and
of TE Lawrence Lawrence of Arabia the
very eccentric British oxford-educated
archaeologist who ended up helping to
lead a revolt against the Ottoman Empire
during the first world war now the
important thing to say about this is
that I think that many historians have
now pointed out is that actually the the
Arab revolt although it's a sort of big
you know because of the fit the movie
and all the rest
it's a looms big in our consciousness
actually was a very small sideshow
compared to the real heavy lifting
forces that were actually removed the
Ottoman Empire and these were the
British and Australian forces that
conquered Baghdad in 1917 and also I'm
going a different route Concord and
Jerusalem in 1917 and the general
Allenby so what we always think of as
the Arab revolt was really in that sense
a sort of very romantic sideshow and
launched earlier causes himself a very
controversial character and I talked
about him in my book and so what
actually made the difference in getting
rid of the Ottoman Empire wasn't in fact
an Arab revolt but it was actually the
British Australian and New Zealand
forces who had failed at could in just
outside Baghdad in 1915 and also failed
and the Churchill's
political leadership to capture the
Dardanelles and thus Constantinople the
Ottoman capital also in 1915 and 16 so
come 1918 the British have found
themselves occupying an enormous stretch
of what's now the Middle East now they
had during war itself decided to try and
carve it all up and there was a man
called Sir Mark Sykes and the matte
Frenchman called mr. George picot and
they put together a treaty carving up
the Middle East and this was called the
sykes-picot agreement now this actually
is more controversial I think than it
should be because in fact the
sykes-picot agreement wasn't really
properly implemented one of the main
reasons was that the time it was
implemented they hadn't actually
conquered the most of the Middle East
and the Russian Czars Empire still
exists existed and the reason we know
about sykes-picot agreement in fact is
that the the Communists when they took
power in mosque in Moscow in 1917 and in
Lenin group and in Petersburg during the
Bolshevik arising decided to publish the
treaty sykes-picot treaty in order to
embarrass the British and the French so
all those parts of the Ottoman Empire
that would have gone to the Russians
obviously didn't go to the Russians
anymore because the Bolsheviks the
Communists didn't want to have any part
of it
here at his treatise and in fact the
British realized that they D actually
given too much land to the French and
when the interesting things that
although the British in the French well
allies during the First World War
like now like in 2004 British and French
friendship was distinctly fragile and
Churchill was spent some of this period
out of office because he is essentially
lost office as a result of the day bakla
in the in Gallipoli and he then came
back to power in a fairly minor role
because of the patronage of David Lloyd
George the famous polity the Prime
Minister and then the 1st December 1918
two men let met in a London in London at
10 Downing Street had accidentally
changed the world and the conversation
between them went roughly as follows
well what are we to discuss at the old
man Mesopotamia and Palestine reply the
younger one tell me what you want
replied the first one I want Mosul
answer the second you shall have it
anything else yes I want to Salaam to
you shall have it the older man replied
but my friend Minister P Shah will make
difficulties about Mosul that the old
man was claimed also and can also was
the French Prime Minister and he
basically wanted revenge against Germany
he didn't he could really couldn't care
less about having a huge empire in the
Middle East but unfortunately for him
some of his politicians did and the era
they particularly wanted where what's
the area this we now call Syria and
Lebanon but in those days Syria was much
bigger sort of amorphous area than the
one at than the current day state of
Syria they under British leader younger
man was the dynamic 55 year old British
Prime Minister David Lloyd George who
was whose I was whose eye doctor was my
great-grandfather and then of course the
reason they wanted to have this some
deal was because they knew that Woodrow
Wilson was coming over and Woodrow
Wilson had all these wonderful
idealistic principles of things like
self-determination and all the rest and
it was one of the things if you want to
have an empire there is not to have
self-determination people over whom you
want to rule so they were basically and
comes to what's now Iraq there were
three Ottoman provinces all villa yet
the the one in the South lived in by the
Shiites was Basra the one in the middle
lived in phenomenally by Sunni Muslims
was Baghdad and then the one in the
north lived in predominantly by Kurds
but also by a smattering of people
closely related ethnically to the Turks
the two commands based around Mosul and
these three Villa yets the only thing
they had in common in fact was the fact
they were all provinces of a much bigger
Empire and the the Ottoman Empire and
under the sykes-picot agreement and the
Mosul Villa yet would have gone to the
French but unlike Churchill and unlike
the British Foreign Secretary Lord
cousin Lord George had this sort of
suspicion that actually the Mosul Villa
yet had lots of oil now I should say
that this is an area of controversy some
people say what the reason why the
British wanted what's now Iraq is
because of the oil but on the other hand
no oil was actually respected and and
discovered until the late 1920s long
after Iraqi and nominal Iraqi
independence and most of the oil was
actually run by the British concession
the angler Iranian oil company which is
now well known here in the States as BP
was British Petroleum and then when it
bought amico and the rest other American
oil companies decided to become BP is
that I think is nicknamed beyond
petroleum we've gone to its adverse or
something so so Lord George realized
that there might possibly be oil and one
or two of the other British officials
also realized colonel ad Wilson
Britain's then acting ruler for the area
so that oil is the only immediately
available asset of the occupied
territories butchered shall have but
they they also realize it's not possible
to give any estimates of the potential
production of Mesopotamia and this can
only be begun when grilling begins and
of course by the time the British
finally did begin drilling it wasn't a
lot it was some while after independence
had been given so consequently although
some people realized there was oil there
I think it's also fair to say that oil
wasn't the main reason and the main
reason why Churchill was interested was
because Iraq was a vital route on the
of the overland route to India from the
British possessions in Egypt
you've always probably heard of India as
the jewel in the crown of the British
Empire and that's what it was always
cabal resolves called which of course it
was until 1947 when he got his
independence from the British and the
one the reasons why the British wanted a
stake in the Suez Canal for example I
didn't want to leave it in towers to the
French was that in fact if you go
through the Suez Canal it drastically
cuts the amount of time it takes to go
from the Mediterranean through down to
the British possessions in India so as
far as Churchill was concerned and as
far as many of the British were
concerned the real key thing was to
protect the overland route and the new
air route because one of the things
happened at the end of the First World
War was that Churchill was given two
positions by David Lloyd George the
first was Secretary of State for war
that's the minister in charge of the
army and then the other one was a brand
new position the Secretary of State for
air which was the minister in charge of
the brand-new Royal Air Force he was he
wasn't the first Secretary of State for
air but he was one of the earliest and
in many ways was the person who actually
helped create the Royal Air Force and
they realised that of course if you
controlled Iraq then you could have safe
Royal Air Force bases all the way from
Egypt through to India and that was
something extremely important but then
at the same time as all this was going
on Churchill also realized that America
America Britain was stretched as
suffering from massive overstretch and
it was very similar to what many people
like Paul Kennedy have said here and
here the states about American
overstretch as well for example I mean
he says that you you will not be able to
reduce the garrison of Ireland to its
pre-war figures figure without an Irish
policy because was the Irish rebellion
was going on at this very time you will
have to maintain this exceptional forces
in Palestine Egypt and Mesopotamia and
then of course there was also a whole
form of India because Gandhi was
beginning his activities and so the
British had need an enormous army in
India failed to keep the area under
British control
so basically Britain had far too many
troops and no money because Whitmer's
bankrupted after the end of the first
world war and this was Churchill's main
concern throughout this entire period
was saving as much money as he possibly
could he said that the military
establishment you were maintaining at
the present time would simply crush the
provinces in the Middle East and prove
fatal to its retention by Britain in
other words Britain was so over
stretched that we could they couldn't
possibly keep it all it's what's the
India Egypt Mesopotamia and Palestine
are all affected prejudicially and they
have it costs far more money to keep
these armies there than they had revenue
here actually I should say India was
different the indian raj paid for itself
but i wasn't anything like the case with
the British armies in the Middle East
and this was again it was long before
oil and so Churchill was also aware of
the fact that because of its rule of
India Britain was he what he called the
greatest [ __ ] power in the world
because of the british raj and at the
same time all this was going on David
Lloyd George was unfortunately
supporting the Greek campaign to get
back to Greek rule all the places you
probably read about in the New Testament
especially in the book Paul's missionary
journeys and in the book of Revelation
the seven churches to Asia because the
Greeks once they once the Ottoman Empire
was defeated in 1918 suddenly saw this
as the golden opportunity to get back a
lot of the land that they had lost as
far back as 1453 when the Gregg
Byzantine Empire was conquered by the
Ottoman Turks and so they actually they
they at first tans including Smyrna
being the biggest which they seized and
which they which they wanted to keep
that keep was Greek because many of the
Anatolian Greeks had lived there since
since the days of the Byzantine Empire
several hundred years before but
unfortunately for them the Turks had a
genius as a rebel military commander and
this was a man originally called Mustafa
Kemal and later on called Kemal atatürk
who became the first president of an
independent Turkey and died peacefully
in 1938 yeah
Kemal atatürk means the sort of father
of the Turks if you like and he was the
person who defeated the British an
Australian New Zealand armies at
Gallipoli and he was now to be the fore
the flesh of the British because the
British was under because of Lloyd
George were supporting the Greeks and as
a consequence the British therefore
we're we're losing because the their
former wartime allies the French and the
Italians thought well this isn't a very
good idea so they said the British found
themselves alone in very similar ways to
which the American America fans felt
very isolated in the recent war so so
therefore the British were trying to
fight all these different battles all at
the same time and Churchill fell to the
real problem is that it was one of money
he says the cost of the military
sandwich from the mesopotamian appears
to me out of all proportion to any
advantage we can ever expect to reap
from that country and he and he says
that this result of the system of having
the british army there was the score of
not villages sandwiched between us
between a swampy river and a blistering
desert inhabited by a few hundred
half-naked native families usually
starving are now occupied and have been
occupied for many months and are likely
to remain occupied in the future and
what he felt was ruinous expense to the
to the British taxpayer because it was
in 1920 there was a major rebellion
against British rule and with the
interesting thing about the rebellion
was that the Sunnis and the Shiites and
the Kurds all united together they
didn't have anything else in common with
each other but they did unite together
in in favour of trying to get rid of the
British now in fact the British were
hummed and hard and that cut a long
story short and Churchill had different
feelings sometimes he wanted to withdraw
all together apparently you don't know
you don't know you know the words
scuttle here in the states is that right
you do all right
oh so because I couldn't use the word
scuttle in the book so I had to say
ignominious retreat
so the British had to the British will
register an ignominious retreat and then
decided no we'd lose so much face we did
in a communist retreat
and also because of the the mandate
system because in 1920 at an attempt to
the Italian town of San Remo the British
were given what
called a mandate for this large chunk of
the Middle East
basically the management team and age
for Mesopotamia the Mosul Villa yet and
for Palestine and an area and so
nebulous area called Transjordan and
which is the bit in between the bit the
Palestinian bit with the Jews without
settle and the and the Mesopotamian
province but that we now call Iraq and
so and I should say that in the book I
try and avoid the the minefield of the
whole Palestine issue because it's been
written about to death in so many other
books and also tend to get shot at from
both sides hopefully not too literally
if you take a very controversial view on
the Palestinian issue unfortunately when
I said that you have to be very careful
what you say The Wall Street Journal
didn't like my my use of metaphors and
so I got in trouble with the Wall Street
Journal for that but basically and what
happens is that a lot of people try and
read the converses of the president back
into the past and it and who said what
to whom and when in some you know
various obscure discussions back ins
from 1915 16 17 and 18 has now become
very significant as to who ought to be
able to who ought to rule which bit when
so the cut a very long story short I do
very fleeting the refer to Palestine but
I try and avoid it where possible
because the book is about Iraq but I
should say the Churchill was pick was
unlike many polish students at the time
he was very Pro Semitic because he's
very Pro Jewish these were upper class
anti-semitism that besmirched so much of
Western Europe was certainly not
applicable to Churchill and Church was
therefore passionately in favor of a
Palestinian homeland and one of the he
was therefore very much one of the
creatures of the State of Israel and one
of the interesting things that when
Osama bin Laden after 9/11 started
talking about the suffering the past 80
years people thought one of those he
talking about
well the suffering the past 80 why isn't
he talking about you know 1948-49 the
creation of Israel well actually the
real reason is that the creation of the
modern Middle East goes back to nineteen
eighteen to twenty one and that's when
the
that whole part of the world was carved
up and therefore actually strictly
speaking bin Laden was being more hiss
was being historically accurate the
other thing he's talking about is that
the Turks under mustapha kamel and
realized that if you lost to the West
which they did in 1918 the only way to
beat them is to catch up with them and
that was Mustafa Kemal's big I later
came out drugs big big policy and that's
what happened in Turkey when he got
control of it after 1923 when he got
back the lands that have been given to
the Greeks what he did was he turned he
abolished the Ottoman Empire and then in
1924 he abolished the Caliphate which is
the big which is the religious title
held by the Ottoman Sultan which means
these ruther sort of quasi religious and
spiritual but also political head of the
Muslim world and it's the abolition of
the Caliphate is the thing that's really
bugs as our bin Laden and those who
follow his view the most so that's
that's the sort of fleeting link to 9/11
and to the Palestinian conflict in my
book I do talk about a little bit more
than that but and do ask questions on if
you want to but I tried to concentrate
on Iraq because there are a bit of
Churchill and that really hasn't been
dealt with dealt with before so
consequently the main thing was the
Churchill felt that Britain's military
forces were extremely weak weak and
maintained with great difficulty and
expense and also as a gain and poor
Americans discovering at the moment we
have not secured a single friend among
the local powers because the Egyptians
were desperately trying to get rid of
the British at the same time and they
did so with some success in 1922 all
there wasn't really till 1956 that the
Egyptians could say they got rid of the
British
altogether so Churchill in beginning of
1921 was made Secretary of State for the
colonies and that meant because he was
always interfering in his and his
colleagues business and so he decided
he'd large decided to make him the
official ruler of the whole area and so
they decided that he says the church
will be declaring or secretary and
Churchill became a sort of Asiatic
Viceroy if you like of the whole Middle
East and one of the first things they
had to do was to
the king for the country which they
wanted to rule this was and they chose
fires out the man who had been the man
who led the Arab revolt with Lawrence
Arabia the problem with flies el of
course that he wasn't from Iraq and in
fact he had no previous links with the
new state that they were creating and so
he was actually needs ant cider imposed
by the British for reasons a gain of
money as one of the things that
Churchill said was that Faisal was the
was the cheapest option he was the one
who's going to save the most money
because if because the British unlike
the French believed in what they called
indirect rule in other words what they
did back with the Maharajah's in India
and said that that ruling it direct as
the French did in Syria in Lebanon and
what they did was they find a nice sort
of friendly local ruler and they put him
on the throne and then they ruled the
area through him and so they had to find
us from nice friendly local ruler and
unfortunately the two people within
Mesopotamia itself the Najib of Baghdad
and Syed Ali were for different reasons
not liked by the local British colonial
officials one was regarded it was
corrupt and one was regarded is a bit
doddery but I mean fine I'll probably
himself wasn't much better but he he was
someone who'd to whom the British felt
the out of favor because he proclaimed
myself king of Syria in 1918 and then
the French unceremoniously booted him
out in 1920 and he had to he was then on
his on his uppers and so Lawrence
forever his friend and who became a
friend of Churchill's and an advisor to
Churchill felt that they they ought to
give him a throne somewhere and so if
they were going to create a new country
they might as well give it to the FISA
so fine so then had to of course had to
rig a referendum and a lot of stuff I
talk about in the book is how Faisal was
chosen and and how he say he would save
Churchill lots of money and then how
they fixed the referendum in order for
fire start to look as if he was the
choice of the of the Iraq the local
people the other thing they had to work
work out of course was what the borders
were going to be now they actually the
borders of some of the other parts of
Middle East as you know so lost them as
straight lines and the reason was of
course they just sort the
the colonial powers often did from the
1870s and 80s onwards him in save
example in Africa they get a ruler and
they just draw a straight line and say
people on this side will be part of this
country this colony any people della
Sera be part of this colony and of
course the problem of that is the peep
tribal groups don't live like that they
live on both sides of the same line and
this was exactly the problem of course
you had in the Middle East now one of
the things I had in the book which was
very nicely drawn on the back cover was
this is what the the area looked like
beforehand eben Saud ruled this large
area here and then someone called even
Russia googled this bit here then there
are various other tribal groups here
this was mesopotamia but this is only
the two villa yet of basra an assassin
baghdad in the north and then you see q8
here which is a slightly different
border from the one it does now and the
book the q8 border as I pointed out
cleave this meeting at unlike this was
actually gone by suppose he [ __ ] and
the Emir of Kuwait and evens out a few
years later
that's why QA comes a bit different now
but you'll see for example there's no
such state as Syria there's no stages
Lebanon or Palestine Jordan anything
like that and there's a huge Kingdom
here the Hejaz and that was where Mecca
and Medina or two holy places of Islam
was situated and it was Hussein the
ruler hereditary ruler or Sharif of
Mecca and Medina whose telephone number
was Mecca 1 now he's very proud of her
his for him very proud of his telephone
number
he was these for the political
inspiration he was the fig leaf that the
British used against the Ottoman Sultan
during the first world war because he
needed to have somebody who had Islamic
credibility and the thing about the
Hashemite family is they were provable
direct descendants of the Prophet
Muhammad and so as is in fact therefore
the current current Hashemite king of
Jordan King Abdullah king of blue is
actually mainly British and that's why
he sometimes people joke that he speaks
better English and Arabic but he's
actually he's trained but I think he
also went to post grad school here in
the States as well if I remember right
but he's trained as a British Army
officer and his mother actually comes
from Rainier where my wife and I live so
he's really he's really more British
than anything else
like the other famous isn't be as mighty
leader the agar cards also probably has
more British than anything else but the
he is also the main thing about the
Hashemites is they're descended from the
Prophet Muhammad as are the kings of
Morocco and so the Hashemite dynasty had
a sort of dynastic hereditary and sort
of link to the to the Prophet and
therefore the British would realized
that therefore the Hashemite family
would have legitimacy however what they
didn't realize of course is that in the
Middle East you don't have one kind of
Muslim you have many different kinds of
Muslim and this is one of the things
that Churchill wrote about he says the
Wahab he asked some of his colleagues
the Wahhabi sect is a feud with the with
the Sunni it is also a feud with the
shear what are the principal doctrinal
and ritualistic differences involved
between the Shia and the Sunni a brief a
brief a very brief answer will suffice
on Churchill became famous during the
Second World War for saying you know
please put on one side of a sheet of
paper but he was a heel was did that he
was doing that from his earliest
political career onwards and then also
just before hand he actually realized
for his horror that you know that the
King Hussein of the Hejaz was actually
in a fairly weak position because even
sound wanted to conquer all his
territory and that section would happen
in 1924 and that's why the king of Saudi
era
that's why Saudi Arabia there's no such
country until 1932 when it been sawed
called the country the heap that he
conquered after himself Saudi and Saudi
Arabia so it's a consequently Churchill
decided he needed to have a conference
because he didn't really know all these
sort of ins and outs so he got a group
of people of forty advisors he therefore
nicknamed his 40 thieves after Ali Baba
and the Forty Thieves and they all went
off to the Cairo which was then
undergoing a sort of semi revolt and was
was trying to get rid of British rule
therefore Churchill's arriving in Cairo
this very extremely inopportune time was
not exactly most welcome and you've
actually got a picture of the 40 thieves
here now you will see if there's any one
person wearing
local costume or what she is wearing at
the fairs and all the other people are
Europeans and that's the significant
thing if the Middle East was actually
basically carved up without any
consultation with local people at all
and you see that and Lauren even
Lawrence of Arabia he's at the back
hiding oh here is this is Lawrence
Arabia that's what it's about but you'd
not as we see him not as we've got used
to him because he's actually not wearing
the the his flowing robes he's not
showing off so so basically they went
they got to carry Oh in nineteen
nineteen twenty-one and as time is
pressing to cut a long story short they
decided that the best thing to do was to
unite the three Villa yets into one and
that was completely scuppered the poor
Kurds because the Kurds actually wanted
independence but that what worried the
British was that they had already lost
what we call Northern Kurdistan to the
forces of kemell attitude because Kemal
atatürk as well as attacking the Greeks
in in the West was also attacking both
the Kurds and the Armenians in the East
hundreds of thousands of our millions of
Armenians had been killed already by the
Turks during the First World War
in fact the first Holocaust was actually
committed by Turks against Armenians and
the and unfortunately for the poor
Armenians and the Turks continued to
attack them and masochism but after the
war was over when Cameron Ataturk was on
the way to reconquer in Turkey for the
Turks and unfortunately but this time
the Congress here in the States had also
said that the the Kurds and the
Armenians couldn't be an American
mandate because they refused to sign the
join the League of Nations and so the
poor Armenians and Kurds really
basically the main victims of 1921
because the northern Kurds have been
recon caught by the Turks the British
were terrified that the Turks were then
invade northern southern Kurdistan was
ruled by the British and so as a result
of that they decided but if they put it
under the rule of the new state they
it would be the integrated with a new
state then it would be much safer now
Churchill himself whereas the putting
Arabs over Kurds wasn't really a very
good idea he was not unsympathetic to
the Kurdish cause so technically
speaking Kurdistan didn't join the new
Iraq straight away they joined it in a
few years later but as we all know the
Arabs totally broke all their promises
to the Kurds and as a consequence the
Kurds have been it basically oppressed
ever since so it not come 1921 Churchill
agrees with all his 40 thieves in Cairo
to create a new state Iraq so it's no
longer called Mesopotamia it's now Iraq
and Iraq including the Kurdish areas the
three so it's the three weather gets
together and then there's a whole bunch
of fun and games which I go through in
my book because fine cell like the
current rulers of Iraq the current term
interim council they wanted to have
legitimacy with their own people
and it was if you want to have
legitimacy then you have to be rude
alone to the colonial power so fine I
was as rude to the British as sometimes
they met the current would in cancel
Iraq feel they ought to be from time to
time to the to the Americans just to
show that they are their own people and
this sort of Sharad went on for about a
year and then Faisal developed a
diplomatic illness and there was a
temporary crisis and the the interim
ruler of Iraq who then came who was then
British decided that he could then sign
the treaty and Iraq in 1922 became a
nominally independent country but under
British League of Nations mandate which
in effect meant ruled by the British and
one of the problems about the way in
which Churchill put together this state
was that he put together an artificial
state that was Shiite in the SAS Sunni
in the middle and Kurdish and tokomon in
the north but but in fact ruled by a
clique of Sunni Arabs who had fought in
the revolt in the desert with fight with
FISA against it against the Turks and so
between 1922 and 1958 they kicked the
Iraqi Kingdom the monarchy was ruled
very undemocratically by a small clique
around whoever the king was Faisal
himself didn't live very long his son
didn't live much longer either and in
fact died in very suspicious
circumstances some people felt that he
was eyelid murdered if not by the
British by people who were in British
pay and then there was a young the young
grandson then was King until he was
murdered in 1958 and the man called Nuri
al-said was the fact that the effective
real ruler of Iraq except for a very
short time in 1941 when there was a
revolt in Iraq where they decided that
they want the the Arab National Society
they want to decide with Hitler which of
course was not a very good idea because
the British weren't going to have that
and so the British then we invaded Iraq
and managed to to really conquer it and
put back the regent and put back nor
outside into power and that happened to
like in a 58 when the Hashemite dynasty
was completely massacred there are some
some of the Hashemite cousins managed to
escape and in fact the pot of lung and I
was brought up as a child is absolutely
filled with sort of polish exiled
governments and princes Iraqi exile
governments and princes and you get very
nice polish delicatessens very nice
Iraqi shish kebab places you know and
well that's all because of these exiled
kings and princes and all the rest some
of whom would like to go back to Iraq
but of course the now because now that
Iraq is independent will probably won't
have a chance because of course they're
all Sunni Arabs and they're also really
focus from outside Iraq itself so in
1958 there was a revolution in which the
Kipner monarchy was overthrown and then
one of the things in the it was the in
my book I then go about telling him
either had the sad story how it
eventually all lent sort of ended up
with Saddam Hussein and and the results
we all know and the oppression of it of
the whole of the people of Iraq until
2003 when he was overthrown and I then
say of course the end it was really
sadly all Churchill assault not a
Churchill knew it at the time but
nonetheless it was it was all the anger
that Tim and I get talked about various
scenarios now because I wrote this being
they insisted on a scenario at the end
of the book
which I wrote in March 2004 sadly and
the situation really hasn't changed all
that much we now have a proper interim
government because aim was for this book
to be published by late by July that had
the official handover of power and I say
that only now is the Shiite majority of
Iraq after centuries of first Ottoman
Sunni rule then Western imposed Sunni
rulers and then followed by Sunni
military dictatorship and by the bath
party and stamp Hussein they will do
part of a country in which they can have
a major say but of course we don't know
what the Shiites
will want to do and of course the people
who American so is a fighting at
fighting as we speak in larger focus are
the Shiites and they are 60% of the
country and whether they will end up
wanting to have a genuine democracy or
will avail what want to end up having a
theocratic Lee and democratically
elected theocratic Iranian style regimes
we there's an interesting question of
speculation which I don't really go into
in the book because it's but I'm happy
to try and answer questions bad so yes
so the first question I do talk about
what he did because of course I have to
give a 40-minute actually exceeded my
time I should have given a 25 minute
summary now I took 30 minutes but but
yes I mean actually what he could have
done this has kept it in its three
component thoughts he could have had a
Kurdish state in the north and you could
have you could have a Sunni state in
them in the middle and you could have a
light state in other words you could
have got the three villa yet and that
would have been the time to split them
because trying to split them now is a
very difficult thing because now of
course like you had like the huge Shiite
minority you've got in Baghdad and also
the very large tokomon minority and the
large Sunni Arab minority you've got in
Kurdistan you've now got large
minorities living in those historic
areas that makes splitting the country
up much more difficult and an article I
wrote in the Richmond times-dispatch
which some of you might read possibly
that I talked about the interesting idea
of former American
Croatia Peter Galbraith who's used to
the breaking up of states where he
actually advocates would you might call
a Swiss canton or idea for a rock you
couldn't break it up into those three
bits anymore but you could break it up
into smaller bits and local issues could
be determined by the local Canton and
then things like foreign affairs and
defense could be decided by the by the
iraq wide government and if Churchill
had split the state up into well have
split it in into its core kept it rather
he needs three original component parts
back in the 1920s then you wouldn't have
had the kind of artificial state you
have today and I think that was the
option that that he could have had and
sadly chose not to follow I mean Jordan
was a teeny weeny country it's got no
natural resources at all and actually
Jordan is one of the few stable
countries in the whole in the whole
region
I mean comparatively speaking of course
was not completely stable but in
comparison to many other countries is
comparatively stable and basically
Jordan is the bit that wasn't part of
files Mesopotamian Kingdom and wasn't
part of Palestine so and since abdullah
faiz Saul's brother was on the way to
trial we conquer Syria from the French
half his brother and they said well why
did we make you a mere of Transjordan
and said Jordan was created as I sort of
expedient to stop an invasion of Syria
by Arab irregular troops but yet it's
survived is perfectly viable independent
state well but partially yes I mean but
it's still there and it still exists and
I can help feelings the other three
states like that the three Iraqis sort
of three Villa yes they've split into or
put into made original smaller states
could have survived equally well and so
could the Kurdish one could have done
very well cuz it has the oil and there's
some oil in the Sunni thus a little bit
of oil in what would it be in the Sunni
state and then of course the southern
part
Basra is one of it was one of the major
trading areas of the Middle East I mean
Basra was one of the major ports and if
it would have survived as very
successfully as a trading nation so I
feel that's the option he should have
gone for myself yes
you mentioned that the you said the
Kurds the Sunnis and the Shiites have
united in a rebellion against the
British do you think there's a prospect
that the Kurds and the Sunnis might join
with the Shiites now overcome their
differences because they're so angry at
the Americans well I mean I would hope
that they would unite not in way that
harms current American troops there but
when Americans leave and then I would
hope that they would because nowadays
the problem is is what's called failed
States if you have a failed state which
of course the former Yugoslavia was
which disintegrated into bloody civil
war with hundreds of thousands of people
killed then you have a real mess and so
I hope that Iraq works because now to
split Iraq up in two different different
countries would be an incredibly
dangerous thing to do so now I would
hope the people feel Iraqis rather than
Sunni or Shia or or Kurd but it's even
your guess is as good as mine in many
ways I've always followed the advice of
Oxford historian Timothy Garton ash who
was asked to lecture on work with a
central Europe and he was asked to do
this in 1989 and of course you know this
is February 1989 at the big divorce
conference come the end of 1989 there
wasn't a single communist regime left in
Central Europe that's something nobody
could have predicted and the economists
in fact they all see the world in night
and they published in 1989 the world in
1990 and in the world in 1989 they said
because most of the communist regimes
are falling but we know that the
presidents of Bulgaria and Romania will
be able to stay in power and the day I
picked that up from a train station in
London it was the day that Ceausescu was
shot so so I've always been slightly
worried about you know diagnosing the
future but I certainly hope that the
Iraqis see themselves now as Iraqis what
you need is enough secular Shiites
to be able to unite together with
secular nonviolent Sunnis and Kurds and
to form a unified Iraqi state because
then you weren't built at the only way
to have a theocracy if people vote along
tribe along religious lines then you
could have a 60%
Iraqi Shiite majority and in which case
you could have a real mess
but his people yes so yes so you never
hear about his poisoning gas poisoning
in fact that he was a extraordinary
violent ruling around the time that he
was never the British Cabinet and say
something about Oh got a quote nice try
I was actually looking for that very
quotation just but just before coming
where was I got the actual quote yes I
mean basically he he was in favor of
using yes you're right she's actually
that's right I think you should
certainly proceed with the experimental
work on gas bombs especially mustard gas
which will afflict a punishment on
recalcitrant natives without inflicting
grave injury upon them so who so the key
I mean you could look at it either way
basically I know the church law was a
real slob who was he with use gas at all
or that he was totally mistaken in that
he actually felt that he wouldn't
actually kill people oh he did
absolutely yes so so I think he doesn't
so so I think the truth is he doesn't
come well out of it after him they offed
oka some about 20 years after him in
fact yes absolutely
he actually thought I mean he'd he
looked good I mean I looked at the
archives on this and some interest and
because of the controversy and Harris
that's fine he stops can be wiped out
half the ball no come on us come on
without too much down to Germany
absolutely yes leading president in fact
yes I mean absolutely and in fact
therefore Churchill and felt guilty
about that so bomber Harris was the only
royal air force commander during the
Second World War who wasn't made of Lord
he was he was given a baronetcy which is
a sort of hereditary knighthood but they
were too embarrassed to make him Lord
that's right he was Rhodesia but I think
was mainly embarrassment about the huge
devastation he did the civilian
population who was yes him he was
extremely inefficient way of conducting
wolf it didn't actually salt shorten the
Second World War by a single day you
know which of course it was a real mess
but yes you're right I mean bomber
Harris son has a lot to answer for not
mentioned that oil factors because in
the book on chobe Saint John filming
it's very clear to her church was very
conscious of the loss of Baku it's
already quite influential yes awful if
did that car boy
yes and then this actually say most of
his hours in want to make sure that the
oil cursing me about this new vaviiova
didn't regard it as important according
to what he said and then Churchill knew
it was there but also didn't regard it
is important and the person who knew
that he was there and that it was
important was Lloyd George but that's
talking only about the oil of Iraq um
they said Churchill certain knew there's
plenty of oil elsewhere but they feeling
about a rocky oil then he didn't really
think it's very important but I mean you
know he but yes but if you talk about
another cut yes but other parts of
middle-east yes I mean you know things
like what's now Saudi Arabia and all
those places yes they're certain knew
that Alda was there because that coup
had been lost to the Communists as a
result of the Bolshevik Revolution and
Churchill was Churchill actually wanted
to go to the west to have a war with the
bolsheviks that was the other thing that
[ __ ] yes he did absolutely and Lord
George thankfully said no he regards
this as Churchill as obsession but the
problem was that because Churchill was
obsessed wrongly to go into all with
Russia when Churchill read equally angry
letters saying are but you shouldn't go
to war you shouldn't sign with the
Greeks against the Turks although George
was able to say I is budget but you're
obsessed with Russia and therefore
ignore what he was the correct advice
Churchill was giving him bad Greek
recent Turkey and that was a mistake
that was a pity right yes we talk about
the role of Iraq's neighbors
historically speaking the Turks and Iran
then parsha in terms of you know I guess
the history and what modern-day what
modern-day role they can play and how
they might be affected by or affects the
modern the the new Iraq posts on Hussein
yes was the Turks are very worried about
what might happen with the Kurds and of
course they took among minority
is-is-is they're sort of way into this
Lu influence with in Kurdistan because
they want they said he want to protect
their own people and in the 1920s
chemical given half a chance would have
recon Kurd the whole area and therefore
take would have become a major oil power
as well in Iran the main major worry at
the time was the was that the Soviets
might invade it so there was actually
I'd been created in detail in the book
but in the church locker there's massive
imagined material on the enormous
expense of the British Army in Iran as
well and of course this was the same
time that Turkey was modernizing and the
camel Ataturk Iran was also modernizing
under the press under razor SH are the
father the father of the first thing
they became they also became relate but
more well known Shah of Iran and so but
unfortunately whereas with Turkey and
taking in a democracy Iran went the
other way and of course ends up as a
dictatorship much to the ruin now of
course of the poor Iranian people and of
course the Iranians also have a major
Kurdish problem because there's an
enormous Kurdish population within Iran
as well and there's also a very major as
a by Ani or a very population also
within Iran and if the if as a Bayan
created trouble and of course that's
we're back who is back who is the oil
city of Azerbaijan then that would
create enormous problems for the
Iranians because they would lose some of
their biggest oil bearing districts so
it's so in fact during the war between
Azerbaijan and Armenia you had Shiite
Muslim Iran being very sympathetic to
Christian Armenia as opposed to their
fellow Shiite Muslim state as a buy on
since this is a bit of a mess but
they're all worried is that was what we
will hear on go will the theocrats win
and in the book I wrote a few years ago
I said that I actually or the foolishly
said I think thought they would lose by
now and I was unfortunately the election
this year they actually increased their
power the theocrats which is very
unfortunate for my prognosis skills you
know but but but also I mean I saw the
beginning of Brzezinski on television a
few weeks ago here in the States and he
was saying that the the time bomb of
Iran of Iran is the fact that most of
the young people in Iran a pro-american
or so played pro anti secret
if even our not pro-american and
eventually there will be such a majority
within Iran but the the Iranian
ayatollahs won't be able to be in power
forever and if that's right
maybe Iran is bad news now but in 10 or
15 years it may be as a big meal for
jiske we'll be right in which case you
have a moderate democratic Iran where
women can vote you know and all that
sort of thing all sort of things is
currently forbidden in the Middle East
right on the borders of Iraq and able to
steer them in the right direction as
opposed to the wrong one given the
majority of the Shiite population in
Iran and now majority Shiite population
in in Iraq do you think that there could
be any kind of coalition building across
the border lines where Lebanon could
have a oh they could end up trying to
you know unify with Iran or something to
that effect I think unification might be
unlikely because of course there
although they're Shiites they're Arabs
Shiites and of course during the
iran-iraq war they didn't all rebel in
favor of the their fellow Shiites in
Iran as the Iranians had hoped they
would so but on the other hand there's
every chance that the two countries
would become very closely aligned
because they both be Shiite powers and
she had powers with enormous fines of
oil reserves and their respective
countries which could be quite
disturbing to what extent does religion
play in the political divisions amongst
a singular group like the Shiites for
example for example I mean you'll have
more conservative Shiites versus more
liberal Shiites theologically yeah I
think that's right I mean I think we
tend to see them all as one big sort of
hideous mass I think that's very unfair
the moderates because there aren't
genuine moderates I mean President
Khatami of everyone really want wants to
have a you know what it's have a much
more moderate regime I mean
unfortunately so what I'll have an
Islamic regime but he wanted to have a
moderate Islamic regime and and
unfortunately and some people say that
the fact that Iran was lumped together
in the axis of evil
really actually played into the hands of
the the extremist Shiite ayatollahs
because there was a highest look you see
there's Bush and you want to be friends
bushing it he called you part of the
axis of evil so so actually but so that
yes there are huge differences within
both within Sunni and Shia Islam I mean
this kind of Islam you have in Jordan is
very different from the kind of Islam
you have just over the border in Saudi
Arabia
for example yes was created what was
your advice regarding the pre-emptive
war ooh
that's a very difficult one happy try
and be careful cuz I want Democrats it
well I was but I was I did have an
opinion but I had to sign some great
oath in blood that I would never reveal
my views you know and now in fact a
memorandum I wrote in my brief time
advising his government was so secret
that I can't now read it myself and so I
can't read my own sir so I now can't
read my I can't read it till twenty
thirty four and unfortunately I put my
copic so paranoid about it I put it in
such a safe place you know I can at home
I know I can't find it anymore so so I
can't remember my exact wording what's
the time but I I tended to think that it
was much better to have done it with UN
legitimacy if you possibly could have
and there are those who thought that
only we waited until the fall of 2003 we
could have got that new end legitimacy
but that is a very difficult question
that's a big what-if question
I'm the punt so I mean I did not mean in
the kizomba in the Kosovo war my great
fully with both American and British
governments that usually the pre-emptive
war was a good idea because it it
protected the Kosovars from being
massacred and when hundreds of thousands
of Bosnians had been massacred in the
1990s we did nothing about it there's
nothing to stop it
like 7,000 massacre to destroy pronita
in 1995 so when you went to war in
Kosovo I mean although some Kosovo
Albanians sadly did die because we
didn't we did it all by air and supposed
to with using ground troops which the
British would have preferred nonetheless
we are able to saved hundreds of
thousands lives and so that was a good
thing
we did that with the legitimacy of a
NATO operation and so I'm I tend not be
so worried if it's if there's a
legitimate international body doing as a
human rights thing I tend to worry far
less than if you're doing it
unilaterally and that's my big worry
about the way in which was done it was
done in a unilateral way but therefore
alienated and a lot of people who would
otherwise be very pro-american and since
I'm a very pro-american Briton not just
because I'm married to an American and
this I found rather worried say any
other one more one more yes one more
then sadly time has
but yes maybe a little bit of a trick
question I'm a British citizen as I am
totally unable to vote and so therefore
I better not I said I want Democrats and
Republicans to read Churchill's Foley
[Applause]
Christopher Catherwood is a history
professor at Cambridge University and
the University of Richmond
Churchill's folly is published by
Carroll & Graf for more information
visit their website at avalon pub comm
next week on history on book TV Todd
Tucker examines the ninth